all of the television programs and all
the things we don't were all very
important but what would the urgency of
the landing on the moon everything was
checked and checked and checked again
because if we'd messed up I mean there
would have been a lot of people very
very disappointed and when you look back
now realized there was 220 million
people in Europe watching it Goonhilly
had done a lot of the broadcasts from
America showing the launches of various
vehicles that went into space from
Mercury Gemini right up to the Apollo
series with the Apollo series they
showed all the launches because
everybody was very interested when they
launched on the Tuesday the way they
went and you think well this is going to
happen now
and because we achieve so many of the
launches so many we always felt involved
with the project and when finally they
got to the moon they went into the lunar
orbit and they broke free and by that I
mean the atmosphere and the old
operation control area was electric it
was electric nobody spoke there was no
need to speak as if somebody else had
spoken I think they were broken the
spell finally when they held March and
they came down
we were almost walking down there a step
at the time with him because we've been
involved with her we felt part of it and
when they finally took off and they
joined me the command module and
literally it was all over it was a
wonderful wonderful experience I can't
really explain exactly what it was like
when I left in the morning I walked out
the door and if someone had said to me
you'll be back here in 50 years time to
talk about it I wouldn't have believed
it it was two very important things that
went on the landing on the moon in kun
Italy handling the broadcast my
responsibility on the night of the
broadcast I was in charge of the
television switching patching from the
communication equipment through the fee
various fees and then the outlet which
would go via the microwave link up to
BBC for you or for for the UK now a lot
of people thought that the picture some
of the moon came directly to khun heli
but they didn't they came eventually
because of a satellite failure over the
Atlantic
it came in by a very long route it came
from the moon to Australia Australia to
America America across Japan in Japan to
Goonhilly when I came here nearly six
years is only number one number two came
in in they built in the late sixties it
was just a modern version of number one
number one well they call it Arthur now
it was built to a design which was
typically British it was built like a
battleship every one weighs 1100 tons I
mean it is there forever
it had a character and even though it
was built like a battleship it is the
grand old lady of Goonhilly just hope
it'll always be here gern Healy was
built on this site because it used to be
a radar station during the war important
thing at the time when the satellite
system started coming in they wanted to
be as far west as possible and as far
south as possible and the best sight
they found was on Goonhilly downs I came
to Cornwall
in the early 1960s to work at Goonhilly
when I got here I looked around and saw
have I made the right choice it was a
bleak dismal windy place I just didn't
think that I made the right decision but
um I'm afraid 60 odd years later I did
make the right decision I'd been part of
it as far as concerned I was there I'd
done it and I think I achieved a great
deal and it's a legacy that will go on
my great-grandchildren say hey my
granddad was involved with that to be
that is it that's the legacy and
it was a great part of my working life
at gorilla